she was 20 years old certainly a lot of
people that may pass judgment may think
I'm just an old sleazy rich guy going
after a young hot woman it doesn't
bother me at all I don't I don't really
care I just loved you guys on the show
how are you doing in all of this we all
have each other here you know also under
our roof is Sarah my ex-wife Sarah and
her husband the children are here and
we're safe and we're healthy and that's
more important than anything else it's a
crazy time you know everybody is
affected by this one way or another I
think we feel fortunate we all have each
other I know he loves you and you're
part of a big family now you got a lot
of attention for the closeness between
you and your ex and between Giuliana and
and Sarah now that's got to feel even
more magnified because you're staying
together alive it does the kids are here
all the time of course and which makes
it even more sense that you know Sarah
and Shawn would be here we we've we've
just sort of adopted this naturally sort
of this game plan of we're all in it
together Julia how is it for you because
you and Sarah were seen as very close on
the show right yeah we are very close
even more now I mean you have fun think
she's upside with John and I'm upset
with Michael he just you just gets him
away time and then John and I get the
guy time
Sarah revealed that she's been battling
breast cancer right how is she and how
are you guys all handling that as a
family Sarah was diagnosed with breast
cancer in February at the time it was
unknown how invasive it may have been
she had a surgery and it was still
uncertain what the extent of it was did
some testing it was becoming invasive so
she had us she had it actually she just
had her second surgery I think three
weeks ago so while we're under
quarantine and
thankfully the prognosis is very
positive we're hoping no chemotherapy
but with radiation therapy she should be
okay
and with the craziness of what's going
on
she's maintaining good perspective and
she's she's doing okay you guys are both
close with her are you a little bit
scared at all what's that just been like
for you
I asked Kara but I track not show that
today and this is not you know cause if
I I don't like I'm a kind of person that
I'm like oh my god I'm so sore you know
I like to get more training yeah you
don't just say something for the sake of
false comfort what is the exact dynamic
of you guys and I wonder with Sara maybe
not feeling well if it's almost helping
to be under the same roof maybe Matt's
and CeCe each have their own room we had
a we have a very nice guest room and
that's where Sean and Sara are staying
and we have our bedroom thankfully the
house has like nice open spaces
was that just a quarantine decision like
we as parents want to be under the same
roof for max and CeCe or just happen it
just happened never I'm gonna see peach
max it didn't happen before the corona
pampas it was almost developing that way
Sean and Sara were spending a lot of
time here we were having we we had max
and CeCe here a lot because of Sara's
health issues and surgery and so so they
would just come over guest room and then
it just became you know one big like
sort of nouveau Brady Bunch family that
we have wow I'm loving I'm ready for the
spin-off for you guys what tips do you
maybe have for creating such a cohesive
blended family that does work so well
together like that we're all very
accepting people were people who have
seen a lot of different things in life
when it comes to my marriage with Sara
it wasn't easy wasn't just oh we're
divorced and now hey we're best friends
you know things take time to heal but
the ability to forgive to move on Sara
and I probably found
different kind of loving relationship
course we stress children together and
that if nothing else for both of us that
was first and foremost do seem to have
built a great life for max and CeCe
what do they think about you guys all
being under one roof together I would
imagine it's actually kind of great for
them yeah it I'd like to think it's it's
a wonderful gift for them I guess to see
despite having gone through their
parents getting a divorce
seeing how you can reconcile and there
can still be law and they're good now
suddenly we're even bigger family
[Music]
happy six-month of ursery what it what a
rollercoaster you've probably had from
being on the show to now being in the in
the middle of this pandemic what's the
first six months of marriage been like
for you guys we're very very lucky
people we found each other under such
odd and improbable circumstances in our
life before Juliana even made it to
America which was last July and then we
got married in October we it wasn't easy
to try to keep that going while we were
working on her k1 visa to come to
America but I was fortunate enough to
have independence and the resources to
be able to travel to be with her roughly
a week out of each month for almost two
years well I loved it and this was the
dream and that we would be together of
course not I love it it's just fine I
think yeah normal couples nothing that
and that's like created a big you know
cracks in the relationship you guys seem
very touchy-feely you're kissing each
other you're you're putting your arms
around each other and I love seeing that
is your relationship in a better place
now than it's ever been
where are you kind of at right now
sometimes you guys did get some
criticism I think at the outset you know
at first glance people look at you and
they talk about your age gap and and of
course naysayers say that that won't
work what would you say to those people
for us I I think mostly we got used to
not worrying too much about the judge
you know negative judgment or criticism
there's 10 20 30 wonderful people that
we've gotten to know or then they you
know love the story love the story with
Sarah and Sean and the kids and the
whole thing that that makes it that's
what really we spend more time thinking
about that then
somebody who just wants to say oh she's
a gold digger or I'm creepy old dude
have you guys talked about having kids
together what are your next steps as a
couple no I'm gonna be like my Korean
right before the sort of stay-at-home
orders the quarantine orders came
through she was just right there to
getting right back into work modeling
work great modeling work in New York
City and elsewhere and she does she
still wants to keep that going for a
while but we want we want to have a
family and she's she's such a loving
wonderful person she's wonderful with
Max and CeCe
how many kids do you guys talk about
having have a timeline when the time is
right the time is right Maxon Cece get
excited about the idea of more siblings
oh yeah actually Sarah would love for us
to have another baby Sarah was talking
about it like I hope you guys are
planning to have babies because I want
to love to feel in a way that motherly
bit again she doesn't want to have any
more children and Maxie are great but
you know she could see the cool aunt he
talks about having a prenup and Juliana
you expressed your concerns and then you
kind of said okay forget it we won't do
it we're not doing it no prenup doesn't
make sense it was something that was
creep you know created some unnecessary
tension in the relationships and
ultimately it wasn't something that was
really going to dictate everybody's
well-being one way or you know so we're
okay well in Julianna I loved that you
were always saying I want my financial
independence to
for sure so that's like me now that I'm
this my prenup is you're not gonna be a
problem for me to sign something like
that even if I'm not getting nothing did
she find out nothing
oh so looking back you wouldn't have
maybe had a problem with signing it do
you think you just didn't understand it
really then I couldn't understand what
was that about you know and so would you
sign one tomorrow I could sign right now
this is kind of a tough question but you
mentioned your business some people
questioned how much money you had asked
about your cars or things like that on
the show so where are you at financially
right now and I don't know how much
that's been affected by the court Oh
Astor disaster because it started
actually before the coronavirus because
one of one of my main lines of business
is importing French line in October of
last year actually right around our
wedding out of nowhere the current
administration instituted a 25% import
duty on French wine so that eats so much
into what you're trying to do you have
to adjust and while you're adjusting
then suddenly virus lockdown one of my
biggest client bases is the New York
City restaurant and you know bar yeah
they work goodbye love it that's
completely shut down now so are you
concerned in all of this because a lot
of people are yes without question I am
are you guys having to cut back yeah
well I mean lifestyle changes anyway
we're all here right we're not traveling
we're not going out to eat we're not
going into the city we're not doing this
or that so I mean naturally lifestyle
changed but you know one step at a time
I also wanted to ask you about I just
loved the the post that you did after
some criticism came you guys his way for
the picture of max orient the makeup um
tell me about posting that and and what
you wanted to say to everybody I love my
son so much and I appreciate that he can
be his own person and this was just a
silly thing he put he put up on his
Instagram because they were playing like
a truth or dare and so he had one of his
friends did makeup on him and I thought
you know this is really cool and the
fact that he had that his own confidence
to put it out there this is me you know
supporting my son is max I think you're
a special guy and I'll celebrate you the
90 day family around the world are
staying home together Mondays to TLC so
maybe tease a little bit what people
will see in this special just what
quarantine life is for us you know
Giuliana will we see you and Sarah
together as she's still your best friend
you'll see Lana and I have been doing a
lot of music together I'll let you guys
go but you know Michael I gotta ask you
cuz I always wondered this we are you
ever insecure dating a woman this
beautiful
I like she's one of the most beautiful
women I've ever seen did that an issue
ever come up in your relationship
because you got to think I've landed a
real catch here I don't take it for
granted we were meant to be together
and yes she just happens to be the most
loving most beautiful most bright
spirited person I've ever met
I don't know what to say
great I'm predicting a quarantine baby
could be if it it would be an accident
[Music]